here in London they've learned about a
thousand developers to the Google campus
free beer and free t-shirts helps a bit
to get them excited about the latest
Google creations so far so good while it
could tune into the Google announcements
from home many come to meet up and
socialize with fellow developers and
techniques some were more serious than
others it's bit more chilled up here but
of a sedate affair the silent disco is
what they call it but the focus is still
the same get app developers excited
across the entire business whether it's
manipulating a mobile whether it's
connected cars whether it's the latest
SmartWatch they want developers
designing for the google android system
basically we come here to see what what
Google's doing was Android that's what
I'm mostly interested in but also
obviously the free food and drink and I
also wanted to see google glass life I
haven't seen that before if your
developer you can come today try it on
as any discussion whether some come to
play with a new hardware some come to
talk software many just come for the
free food but those that were Google's
target market are clearly pretty excited
by the opportunities to get creative
that should be financially beneficial
for both we see that google is going to
dominate the world they they just go
into cars the huge device is small
devices laptops everywhere so it looks
like Android developers soon be very
rich Caroline hide Bloomberg